mais
de la formule 1 sur une musique du film
flashdance un mélange des genres que
vous propose la troupe de déclic théâtre
avec son spectacle plan c
donner l'illusion aux spectateurs qu'ils
sont au cinéma à travers des
improvisations de 20 minutes
le concept le public choisit une image
une musique ainsi qu'un titre
les comédiens parts de ces trois
éléments pourront faire une histoire
comédie drame western
les possibilités sont multiples elles ce
qui a demandé un gros travail de
préparation pour la troupe
on s'est réuni on a regardé plein
western à regarder plein de films
policiers on en fait on a voilà on a
essayé de se créer vraiment une culture
commune pour les comédiens de plans
c'est pour que quand on se dise ok on va
jouer à un thriller et ben on a tous la
même référence de thriller et on sait où
on parfois
les premières choses qu'on se dit c'est
récupérer les codes assez rapidement
pour que ça parle à l'imaginaire commun
des spectateurs pour que en fait ils
puissent se dire c'est vrai que c'est
les trams des westerns habituel et on
reconnaît le genre de film un spectacle
d'une heure quinze qui aura nécessité un
an et demi de réflexion
on est dans un dans un format qui permet
au public de voir de voir plusieurs
facettes de ce qu'on peut travailler on
n'est pas frustré si on vient voir
voilà une impro qui a duré une heure et
demie ou une heure et que finalement ça
soit juste une impro complètement
dramatique et puis qu'on n'ait pas
trouvé ce qu'on est venu chercher
donc on se dit voilà au moins avec 3 un
pro il y en a il ya en a pour tout le
monde
le spectacle se joue dans les cinémas de
proximité prochain rendez vous le 10
juin à saint cyr l'école
[Musique]